Package some Valentine's Day love to share with family and friends.
Here's how.
You'll need party favor containers, Reese's Peanut Butter Hearts,...
...and your personal decorating flair.
Fill a favor bag or other container with Reese's Peanut Butter Hearts.
You'll find containers online or at your local craft or bakery supply store.
Next, have some fun!
Decorate with a festive ribbon.
Hershey's Chocolate Hearts or Hershey's Kisses are great options as filler.
Get creative with your containers.
There are many options at your local craft store.
Hershey's makes life extraordinary!
Check out more great ideas at CelebrateWithHersheys.com